[Musique]
la télévision et l'humour ont une place
importante dans la vie quotidienne des
algériens c'est ce que nous comptons
attirail moussa il était une fois dans
un pays que l'on appelle encore
l'algérie sous le séisme des silences
des pénuries des chocas identitaire sur
cette terre vivait le roi fahd
ses 40 voleurs ont dicté par dans un
désordre entretenu tout nous quelle un
volcan de rire et afida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
pêle mêle que le
roi fahd ali avec sa forteresse haute
fidélité fut éclaboussé par la poussée
du volcan il fait mine de lâcher prise
mais sous la déflagration gigantesque
jahier de l'ombre le vrai message et
dureau
et s adosser data c'est la morale est
qu'on voit
[Musique]
ainsi le mtv dans sa langue obscur
invite son roi sur un plateau pour un
grand moment d'éclaircies
[Musique]
c'est
bizarre qui fait la ristourne rouabah la
moto ki-moon en masse il affaiblit la
dina bad se battent au
nominal l'istiqlal trace at home in and
alamo la coutume
filiale dacia si
nous sommes les messagers du roi
soucieux de la liberté d'expression de
ses téléspectateurs mois des
journalistes de 4,4 tout terrain vague à
leur rencontre
la télévision
n'a trouvé
la mince couche à la ruine
et
seulement le messager ne dit pas tout il
en crache des choses à ce chien
téléspectateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le peuple devenu claustrophobe vous le
prendre l'air l'air elle gérer
complètement
[Musique]
complètement oublié
j'ai
complètement
[Musique]
zappé honorable
onoma une belle histoire comme a au
contraire
et pour ceux qui restent et anil et
ravale dit eh bien grâce à lui le don
d'alger est coupée à babel ou à un
spécialiste dans la bourse wall street
ar drone la kiffe à ce niveau
le dow jones qui va
la cour
l'échéance forme en août
vidéo
le dinar
à cause des palabres la vidéo avant tout
sera ou les djinns malheureusement abdou
grâce à sa boîte magique
le peuple téléspectateur va se
téléporter via satellite sur la parabole
des messages et étrangers la voie de non
être legging
[Musique]
c'est bon comme ça ça va ça va
du jour c'est l'algérie 30000 morts en
deux ans pour une guerre civile même pas
homologué c'est beaucoup alors comment
reconnaître les participants c'est
simple les intégristes portes de la
toile et des poils les policiers portent
des cagoules et civils portes du bois
le peuple parabolée est rappelé à
l'ombre
roger lewis et moi
[Musique]
et oui oui
tu aurais l'abbé tout sauf au michael
jackson jeune antenne parabolique et
matraques et
le bouillonnant la policière tout va les
devises
par abonné via l'ukraine n'a pas de chat
bien-être semaine mais a tendance à
beaucoup mal à sa pâte à sel belgique à
stanley dickens la flemme town il tire
goût
vous savez
chez nous
la censure est
carré blanc
c'est pas pour toute la famille
pour la censure pas son soutien envers
la sensuelle acheter un archet nul enfin
l'asn
j'avais remarqué à l'autre clown théâtre
tout le talent y en a marre des mailles
tous à la conf le fauteuil les ports
turcs chez tous les nayais tous à la con
petit bois ou le film bien l'acteur
audiard ans si
la théorie avancée la wii avancer et
avancer or leblad le global
[Rires]
9,9 sur l'échelle richter
ouvre la télévision vrai studio a voté
la censure
ah oui car la dispense argumentaire
à ouaga pour la distance avec les matins
vie l'acteur la seiche à wigan ben
alaoui ben abdallah wigger l'acteur 98
matin
alors que batum a flatté vision sur
l'image de
l'acteur la parole de l'acteur qu'on a
là au mètre carré
où elle mène à tel film gore
et en plus mais toucher n'importe quel
baiser est travers les baisers
illégitime dan s les machines zijin a
donc les baisers les mecs mais l'oms le
code de la famille
oui à des horaires les baisers légitime
que ça même les baisers légitime bien
des limites
[Musique]
voilà qui est mieux